[Music]
good afternoon everybody
and we start again now in a session
called paying for truths and paying for
truths is some a term which can have
many kinds of interpretations and what
we will try and discuss today with Helga
Novotny and Bharat Stein is what those
different interpretations are and what
it means to us in different spheres
Helga is the former head of the European
Research Council she was one of the
founding members of the council and then
headed it that's transformed research
all over Europe and Bharat Stein is now
from our very own Gothenburg here and he
was recently at Oxford University and he
deals with very important questions of
ethics and society and how we make
decisions about those kinds of matters
so from science and society we have
views on how what paying for truth means
a painful truth could mean three things
how do we build institutions how do we
pay for them where truth and all signs
are all kinds of ideas can be discussed
secondly paying for truth means that if
you speak the truth you could be paying
for it you could be in trouble how does
one deal with those kinds of situations
and thirdly you could pay to create your
own version of the truth so let's find
out what our panelists think about these
three versions of paying for the truth
so first of all Helga how do we build
institutions where truths can be
discussed safely and with multiple ideas
coming forth but we have started some
400 years ago or some people say even
longer when the first universities came
about in the 12th or 13th century but
since modern science we have also
universities or other places were in a
systematic way we explore first the
natural world and then later on also the
social world or ourselves so we have
these institutions we call them
scientific institutions universities
research institutions etc now what is
peculiar is if you go to any lab or to
any university you will not find many
people apart from the philosophy
department where people actually discuss
truth if you go to a lab what people are
discussing all the time is does it work
or does it not work you set up an
experiment and you're interested does it
work so of course there is something
underneath it because you are not just
setting things up in a random way you
need years of training to know what you
are doing you need years of also
training in terms of a discipline or
more than one discipline etc to have
this kind of knowledge and and the
skills to produce something and to come
back to your question you know who pays
for it
modern societies don't pay for truth by
setting up these institutions they are
interested in the technological output
they are interested in the kind of
knowledge that comes from these
institutions for the sake of human
betterment to make us more healthy to
cure certain diseases to make progress
in the way even the Grand Challenges
today that we are facing so we turned to
these institutions to look for solutions
to the problems we have but we are not
paying them in order to produce truth
and yet truth is important and for
science I would say truth is not really
something that you can negotiate science
is essential a truth is essential for
science for
for epistemic reasons I mean you need
the basis and you have to get some
agreement testing what you know against
reality
validating it but you also want to have
something that improves the way how we
live and the way how the world functions
so this is you know what what we're
actually paying for and and and the
question of course is if we are not
paying for truth and truth yet is
essential it also binds together the
scientific community you know something
like fraud in science it happens but
there's a very strong inbuilt tendency
to to react very strongly against it
because it is so important to have a
common basis and to know does it work
does it not work so in many ways society
creates institutions to solve its
problems truth is essential for this
problem-solving but society sometimes or
many times doesn't explicitly pay for
truth seeking institutions there the
humanities and Social Sciences play a
critical role you pointed out very
nicely how scientists are caught up in
their work of the day following the
scientific method as it were and you
know doing things honestly but sometimes
this can allow them to make that to miss
bigger things which are happening around
them or new ideas which are coming from
other areas so do you think that is a
room in such in institutions where we
pay for the truth for humanities and
Sciences and the social sciences to come
together in some kind of a meeting place
where ideas makes regularly yeah I think
so and I think the central notion of
this is the idea of impartiality or
neutrality you're not supposed if you
work in science to sort of further any
ideological or religious or
economic interests there are sort of
areas where disinterestedness or
impartiality is the central thing and I
think the humanities and the social
sciences are extremely important for
understanding this similar notion of
impulsivity I mean if you would
summarize human suffering in the world
today I can assure you it has very
little to do that we have not invented
new technological devices or new
medicines I would say that most human
suffering in this world is caused by
that about seventy seventy five percent
of the human population live under
incompetent is functional or corrupt
government institutions so it there is a
very clear sort of notion between the
social sciences and humanities
understanding why this is so and what
can be done to change it and the Natural
Sciences so I'll come back to this very
important point about how human problems
and suffering can be solved by
communicating the truth to leaders and
so on but let's segue into that next
point the next question which is what
are the consequences of stating what you
believe to be the truth in a blunt
manner do you deal with that in a nernst
way I are you supposed to be very
careful about what the consequences are
or do you say what you want to say
irrespective of what the consequences
are do you deal with it in a manner
which rocks the institution which you
work in or could you let certain things
be I was a legendary political scientist
Aaron Wildavsky who said that what our
job is is to speak truth to power now I
can assure you you do not always get
very popular there is one specific
problem sometimes the truth that you
discover points in a direction that you
normatively don't agree with yourself
yeah so for example I would love for
democracy to be a functioning cure
against corruption it is not and that is
of course a problem for myself and
big fan of democracy but that is not the
the major cure for this problem that we
see so that can create problems of
course and then there of course you know
sometimes everyone runs in the same
direction all of your friends all of
your colleagues the whole society gets a
kind of moral panic and they run there
and you feel you are the only one
standing and looking at the same this is
all wrong
take Sebastian Haffner's book about he
was a german journalist who grew up in
germany and his book is published in
1939 so before anyone knew and he
describes who everyone all his friends
all his colleagues went with the nazi
party he was not the only the last man
standing there you know and you can
discover that if you do science yourself
everyone is going in one direction and
you just shake your head and say this is
not okay but Helga yeah in these kinds
of situations in today's world in Europe
or elsewhere in the West in America
scientists often have views about you
know what kind of power supply we should
have nuclear or solar or whatever
whether we should have GM crops or not
whether you know vaccines work or not
and speaking these truths in a context
where you're employed or your rules are
set by someone else can have
consequences how do you deal with us in
your day job as a scientist let me give
you a personal example I was professor
ETH Zurich and one of my colleagues was
mr. Porticus who developed the Golden
Rice now this is a genetically modified
rice species rice corn that he invented
and he was attacked he was attacked by
Greenpeace he was attacked by others he
had enormous problems because he
discovered
in order to get it patented he needed
something like 50 patents and in the end
you know he gave up he wanted to plant
the crop in a field this was not allowed
and when it was allowed he was attacked
etc so he really felt being attacked
from all sides and then I happened to
get to the chance to get an exhibition
space in a museum in Zurich they had
planned for another exhibition and for
two weeks they had rooms free of charge
and I said why don't we do an exhibition
on Golden Rice and we had very little
money so what I did was I got white
cloths and I got students to tell the
story of the Golden Rice by making
drawings and then I asked the students
because just by showing drawings on a
floor you will not get many crowds so I
asked the students why don't you like in
the Middle Ages you know tell the story
so we organized groups of 20 visitors
they had to sign up and then the
students told the story and this became
an immense success and there were
parents who worked in the chemical
industry in Switzerland and they said
you know finally I can come with my
children and my children can hear from
others something you know why am i
attacked etc so what I mean is you need
sometimes intermediator x' you need
storytelling at times we all you know as
humans our storytelling animals from
from the very beginning and by telling
stories you can convey in a space that
is protected because it's not a
university it was a museum at the same
time you had students the story was the
correct scientific story you know of
what happened but you put it also into a
context
and so this was one thing I was able to
do and I think sometimes you know we
have the possibility of coming up with
solutions to mediate and to tell stories
and it's the context that very often is
missing well that's wonderful
I mean that this is a very nice example
of a meeting place of different kinds of
views different ideas so that people can
understand each other and at least
appreciate each other's views if not
move towards a consensus opinion but
that's what the university is supposed
to be about you know we shouldn't be in
our echo chambers we're supposed to
listen to other viewpoints and then you
know have the opportunity thereby to
change our views is that how our
institutions are now or are they become
you know echo chambers or preventing
contrary viewpoints from being discussed
but I think we have a disease from
within you can call it academic
tribalism that most academics like to
think like to speak to people who think
like themselves they want to create
small tribes with like-minded people and
I can say one thing for sure that one
absolute guarantee of becoming stupidest
only to talk to people who think like
yourself but unfortunately there is much
within universities that cater to this
so you allow people to isolate
themselves in academic tribes instead of
forcing people to enter into the
discussion with people who disagree with
them and my personal experience I have
sometimes been critical of my colleagues
in other disciplines is the standard
reaction should be then that you are
invited to have a dialogue that is how
my department act and people who are
invited get very surprised you know I'm
a critic of you why do you invite me
said well we're paid by the taxpayers to
have a civilized discussion at least
trying to find out why we disagree but
this is not the universal mode of
operation instead you are sometimes
ostracized if you criticize but I think
you know you have to break this pattern
really and not all universities are like
this we also have some interesting
spaces called Institutes of Advanced
Study both outside universities the most
famous one is Princeton which was by the
way based on Abraham Flexner very
interesting manifesto in 1939 the
usefulness of useless knowledge and it
became the haven for Jewish and other
refugees from Europe who had to flee
Europe
Einstein was there for no man was there
many others were there so and then after
the war in Europe we had Berlin we had
other Institutes of Advanced Study and
now there is a tendency to set up
Institutes of Advanced Study within
universities because we need a space for
people to meet not just your own tribe
and if you come with an open mind you
can learn a lot and therefore you know
we also have to take a proactive role in
setting up these spaces and making them
work yeah absolutely I think I'm afraid
I have been before such places to have
been very good - not so good I'm a
little afraid you know it's supposed to
leave your your city your home for a
semester or a year to be there I think
these institutions are built on an idea
of just today namely that you can bring
your partner freely with you without any
problems you know they are built on the
idea that leading scholars are either
unhappily married or single and that is
not so much the case anymore so I think
it can be problematic because they
attract a very special type of scholars
but in general I agree we should have
more but you can have this within
university so I think within the
universities is helga saying it allows
different departments people to meet I
remember a friend of mine telling me
that he had a philosopher on a biology
PhD thesis committee and
the philosopher refused to shake hands
with biologists because they could be
infectious and therefore did this and
sort of shaking hands so better
communication between philosophers and
biologists would be useful but let's
move on to that to the last aspect which
is paying for truth and I'd like to hear
from both of you in the context of the
most critical problem facing this planet
which is climate change and its
consequences and mitigating that
requires us to do things soon yet being
for truth that is paying for your
version of truths to be put out is a
serious problem in this context so Helga
as a scientist and science at MIT let me
let me rephrase your question slightly I
think the question really is why is
society not willing to value truth I
mean pay you pay for something that you
consider valuable so the value of truth
in society has gone down and you see
this in in many ways that I don't have
to detail and I think that it's
worthwhile to consider the reasons why
why are people not valuing truth anymore
I think one reason has to do with the
shifting ratio between signal and noise
this by the way is noise and if the
signal is strong in noise you become
indifferent you know you start not to
see the value anymore because it's
strongly noise another reason is going
back to tribalism you know living in a
fragmented society where people tend to
listen to those that confirm your own
views so then there's your tools and
might rose so why should I be interested
in your toes if I have my toes and I get
confirmation from my friends and my my
friends in the cyberspace all the time
so I think these are important changes
in society and to get back to make
people hell eyes again truth matters and
truths has a value I think if this is a
big challenge and coming back to climate
change there are of course these
enormous gaps between what people see
happening at the micro level and then
this immense complexity that we are
unable to understand but again I think
you know by bringing but by using
simulation models by visualizing what is
going to happen and these are not
scaremongering
visuals but just telling people if you
continue to do this this is likely to
happen and you explain it
in an impartial way you explain it
patiently but you have to also tell
stories and use visual means yeah on
that notebook
I mean something like climate change we
are used to because of a mindset from
the Industrial Revolution to thinking no
matter what we do to the planet it will
set itself back to an ok state but what
we are done in the recent past is not
equally different and the consequences
are going to be immense is there room
while others pay for truths
of a kind that the planet is resilient
to whatever abuse we give it is there
room for science and social media and
better communication as Helga put it to
overthrow the big powers for status Co
yes I think so and people our research
show that people are willing even if
they would have to pay quite substantial
cost to do things that are not
detrimental to the planet for example
but only if something can convince them
that most other not everyone but most
other people are also willing to do this
yeah and this is of course a social
dilemma problem I mean it's to make it
simple you're willing to sort your
garbage but it's meaningless if you're
the only one in the neighborhood right
and on the global scale it is the same
so we have to come up with institutions
and and and and new ideas that can
convince people that if they are
contributing most other people will also
be concrete absolutely but we have a
problem here with paying with truth and
that is especially in the social science
and in economics we see fewer and fewer
leading academic scholars at least in
the area that I can see are
participating in this discussion and
more and more hired guns people who work
for interest organizations or think
tanks or special Institute's financed by
you know who and we see an imbalance
here between the leading scholars taking
part in the public debate and these
hired guns and the hired guns are taking
over and that is not good so this is a
very important point if one has to have
debates which can sway public opinion
into doing things about critically
important points for the planet then the
narrative should be set by people in
those institutions we create and not by
those who as you call our hired guns and
that's that's an enormous challenge
which we have
day but to end I'd like ask one last
point to each of you 30 seconds each is
what are the chances of success with
these kinds of problems there what is
the way by which people at large can see
others sorting their garbage and be
involved in sorting their own and also
paying for the truth to be told
look we have been speaking about the
tragedy of the Commons since 40 years
and the tragedy of the Commons is real
and people will start to realize the day
it really hits you and your cow in the
comments and then the free rider problem
which Paul mentioned will solve itself
oh yeah I mean we succeeded in
overcoming the Catholic Church we
succeeded overcoming Stalinist
narcissism
maybe we will succeed in overcoming
Trump is small so that is the of course
the big challenge yes well on that happy
note thank you all very very much for a
very wonderful disguise
[Applause]